hi I'm Erik Bosse and after seeing
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Greenwald's I had questions it turned
the whole Harry Potter mythology as we
know it upside down we're all kind of
feeling on the inside how Ron Weasley's
face always looks on the outside now
we're talking surprise endings here
people's I'm gonna explain this ending
and it's a surprise one so spoiler
warning if you haven't seen the movie
yet okay you've had enough time to click
away let's start with the big reveal
Creedence is a Dumbledore after spending
the movies seeking the truth about his
family origin Creedence barebones
ends the movie aligned with Gellert
Grindelwald who tells him that his name
is actually a really a stumbled or
brother to Albus Dumbledore apparently
confirming this blood relation the young
bird that Creedence had been nursing
throughout the movie suddenly grows into
a full mature Phoenix Dumbledore
explained earlier in the movie that
Phoenix's were part of an old Dumbledore
family legend that the bird would appear
to family members but the last Phoenix
had flown away and Albus didn't
currently have one so credence is bird
being a Phoenix perhaps even Fox though
I'm not sure if this is the same Phoenix
this is supposedly proof that credence
is a Dumbledore now this would make him
the 4th Dumbledore sibling after Albus
April fourth and Arianna Arianna of
course died at a young age during the
duel between Albus April 4th in
Grindelwald but there's kind of a
problem with this it creates some
serious timeline issues these fantastic
beast movies take place in the year 1927
and Albus Dumbledore's father Percival
Dumbledore died in Azkaban prison in
1890 that would mean that if credence
was his son credence would have to be at
least 37 years old and he clearly isn't
Ezra Miller is 26 and in the first
fantastic beasts movies he's supposed to
be around 18 now one way around this
could be double doors mother Kendra she
lived until 1899 meaning that she could
have conceived credence with another man
making credence around 28 but that would
mean credence would have been of 27 or
28 year-old man living with the bare
bones --is that seems kind of weird
right like no shame if you're 20 he
living with your parents I know there's
a lot of you but credence was clearly a
teenager in that movie also if Kendra
had Creedence with another father why
would she keep the Dumbledore name yeah
it doesn't really work so another way
around it some have argued is that
Creedence could be a different blood
relative Dumbledore like his cousin or
his nephew
the issue here is Grindelwald clearly
said brother you could argue that maybe
when Grunwald told credence your brother
been trying to stop you he just meant
brother in the general sense the way
that he addresses all of his followers
as brothers and sisters but come on
Dumbledore is not Grindelwald follower
he's his like biggest enemy if anything
Dumbledore actually said that he and
Britta bald were more than brothers
right right
why would Brenda won't confuse credence
in this moment by calling an enemy
trying to destroy him brother when he
knows that Creedence is specifically
seeking the truth about his family look
it's hard to make sense of this and
hopefully JK Rowling will clear it all
up so CH is usually pretty good about
that now there is another possible
explanation for this little discrepancy
but first thanks to our sponsor than
Sarah watches crimes of Grindelwald main
Pig the concept of time a bit confusing
but there's no reason we have to fear it
look having a nice watch on your wrist
shows people your master a time gives
you authority turns heads admit it you
have been unable to turn your head away
from me this whole video and you would
just be amazed how much this watch from
Vince taro completes your vlog elevates
your game so classy it's well crafted
nice finishing attention to detail and
it's still super affordable for watches
plus it's not that minimal it's cookie
cutter design that some other can't
spells where can't spell is my new
favorite muggle distance of schoolyard
with this you stand out you get noticed
time turn our necklace no thanks I don't
need the time travel I got this black
bag silver surgical grade stainless
steel chrono s with a crocodile top gray
an Italian leather strap baby Mancera
apparently just received their twelve
thousand five star review on their site
a lot of people were loving their
luxurious style you should check out
their site for yourself for their
variety of designs and colors a good fit
for anyone who wants to look their best
and if you jump on this right now then
Ciro is having a crazy epic free Black
Friday sale it's the best prices they
offer all year and it won't last long so
get on it just go do VIN Sarah watches
comm slash new rock star sale too
okay back to this stuff with Creedence
these inconsistencies bring up another
question could Grindelwald have been
lying
perhaps Grenda wall just told Creedence
II was Dumbledore's brothers so that he
could manipulate this powerful obscuri
'l against his foe whom greenwald cannot
attack directly remember like maybe
greenwald hopes credence will get close
to Albus and then he could be used to go
Dumbledore out in the open maybe he
thinks that the idea of Dumbledore
siblings abandoning credence will
further infuriate him against Dumbledore
and
detail earlier in the movie there was a
meeting between Grindelwald and Grimson
the bounty hunter and Grindelwald made
certain to confirm that that half elf
nurse woman was killed why is this
important well she would have been the
only person to confirm the truth was it
a cover-up I don't know really this idea
of Grindelwald possibly lying to me
creates even more logic issues like why
would JK rowling end her movie with a
lie
it cheapens the whole thing and why
would she include the Phoenix is a form
of visual confirmation of this reveal
like folks she obviously didn't want us
to doubt this she wanted it to land as a
cool reveal really to step away from
this I think the majority of audiences
are not thinking as hard about timelines
as we are they just hear oh these double
doors brother cool oh crap I said on a
bunch of crutch like I hate to admit
that Rowling might not be so fixated on
timeline minutiae but there is another
glaring example of it in this movie
Minerva McGonagall is teaching at
Hogwarts eight years before she was born
how the hell like when we see Dumbledore
at Hogwarts in this movie McGonigle
makes a cameo the problem is McGonagall
was born in 1935 and don't I at least
say in fans just made this up in order
Phoenix chapter 15 she states that she
started working at Hogwarts in 1956
after working for the ministry for two
years immediately after graduation 1954
making her first year at Hogwarts 1947
and because ver October birthday she was
born in 35 Rowling wrote that in the
books now you could say that Dumbledore
only refers to McGonagall in this movie
by her last name no first name
suggesting that this could be her mother
Isabelle McGonagall but if you look at
the script for this movie it clearly
labels her as young Minerva McGonagall
sorry now sure we could ever think this
maybe McGonagall has been lying about
her age or maybe she was such a good
teacher that Dumbledore lent her the
time Turner to teach earlier generations
of students apparently academic uses for
the time Turner are totally fair game
ultimately folks I thank both the
McGonagall cameo and retconning credence
as Dumbledore's brother are both meant
to be fanservice not really false flag
so Rowling can prove she outsmarted the
tiny percentage of us super nerds who
overthink her stories like don't get me
wrong we love pretending and competences
conspiracy here at new rock stars
sometimes it just doesn't really add up
it's a time Turner guitar for me the
biggest question is what was that irelia
stumbled or Bey
be doing on that boat and also was it
the Titanic okay I don't think it was
the Titanic the timeline could have
worked out it could have been 1912 but
cornices lifeboat was overturned by a
stormy wave and all the counts of the
Titanic disaster famously described to
see that night as eerily calm but here's
the point of contention for me later in
the movie Lita and Yusuf break down the
truth of the Lestrange family tree yusuf
believes that Creedence is Corvis
Lestrange lead his half-brother but Lita
reveals that she was with baby porpoise
on this boat but because he cried too
much she swapped him with another random
baby
the real courtesan dove drowning while
Rando baby who ended up being Creedence
lived on in New York
if Creedence is actually a really a
stumbled or that would mean one super
significant wizard baby was right across
the hall on this boat from another super
significant wizard baby who else is on
this boat sounds like real hoozue down
the hall against it Minerva McGonagall
she's everywhere negative twenty years
old
yeah the odds seems like a stretch right
though maybe it's possible this boats
whole function was to transport wizards
to America to get them away from Europe
like maybe European wizards exile
they're troublemakers across the scene
and maybe the Dumbledore family could
have put little baby arraylist on this
boat to keep his toxic tantrums away
from them kind of like when the UK tried
to give us Piers Morgan he's no problem
Matt quit speaking of toxic influencers
what was Grindelwald plan in this movie
like how in 1927 did he know a second
world war among the humans was on its
way after Greenawalt escaped from prison
his plan basically had two parts one to
find credence the obscuri Oh apparently
because he's Dumbledore's brother and
two to increase and inspire his follower
base like he baits the orders into
attacking one of his followers so that
he could paint all the ORS as the
violent ones and himself as a peaceful
new order Tristan Lea shows them all
images of the second world war
destroying civilization including a
mushroom cloud now it's pretty nuts that
Grindelwald can predict this like in the
20s some people did suspect the Second
World War was inevitable but how would
Grunwald know about atomic weapons
research for that technology didn't even
begin until the 30s I think there are
two things to take away from this first
Grindelwald is an incredibly powerful
wizard with probably some impressively
clairvoyant divination powers but also
Grindelwald vision for the future world
war ii and nuclear
cost folks that isn't exactly accurate a
bombs were only dropped on Japan by the
Americans of course Europe was certainly
devastated by the war but not decimated
by nukes Grindelwald could have been
referring to the Mughals destructive
tendencies in the general sense or
perhaps he's seen a future timeline that
will be changed by the events of
upcoming movies think about it
historically we know Dumbledore and
Grindelwald will have their epic final
duel in 1945 that was the same year
World War two ended was the war going to
play out differently prolonged until a
nuclear disaster until these wizards
secretly changed the timeline to what we
know it to be today did Dumbledore
secretly save Lutz during World War two
or by later killing Grindelwald a wizard
who claimed he wanted to stop muggles
from building weapons of mass
destruction did Dumbledore and directly
caused World War two and the Cold War
yeah I know my head hurts too I just
know it wasn't our fault I should dig
into this into another video but this
brings us to one last question how
binding is that blood pact between
Dumbledore and Grindelwald like Howard
Dumbledore and Grindelwald going to duel
in 1945 if this blood pact prevents them
from attacking each other as I said
before Gellert and Albus also fought
when they were younger that fight that
led to Ari on its death but April 4th
was also involved so I don't know maybe
he passed their curses to each other
like an intermediary friend passing
messages to the friends who were mad at
each other
got a job as told me to tell you of all
due Kedavra no Ariana I'm so sorry
or maybe Dumbledore's curse ricocheted
and struck re on it because of this
Blood Pact curse between him and
Grindelwald he would literally have paid
for his love for granted wold with his
sisters blood guilt ultimately this
really complicates the history we
thought we knew about Grindelwald and
Dumbledore's final duel
maybe that chocolate frog trading card
got it wrong maybe Dumbledore's great
victory was secretly like more of a
merciful surrender by Grindelwald to his
former lover I guess you can't really
put that in history books maybe we
should the question I'll leave all of
you with do you think the obscurest that
made credence Aurelius and obscuri 'l
could have actually been the same
obscurus that previously infected his
sister Ariana
if the theories about her being obscure
you'll end up being true I personally
think they are comment down below with
your thoughts and follow new rock stars
on twitter instagram @ new rockstars and
for my rants and ramblings follow me on
to
Instagram @e a boss and subscribe to
this channel for more breakdowns
explanations and theories like these and
folks remember when JK Rowling's
characters do something that confuses us
we should take our cues from Dumbledore
and stay calm
alright just a couple of ours is well
calmer than that
[Music]